[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
Kos and today we are going into the
invincible Iron Man as you can see that
statue over my shoulder is the mark 3
maquette from sideshow now let me take
these shades off we see a what's going
on today it is red and gold everything
in memory of a Tony Stark who passed
away at endgame spoiler alert I believe
the world have seen that movie now and
it gives me a great pleasure to bring
the statue I didn't have a movie a
statue of Iron Man and I thought this
maquette definitely depicted the
strength the armor and what has drawn me
to the character over the years now on
and I believe it was Iron Man 2 or 3 I
had a double check when he Ford the Iron
Monger and um that's the big base that
he has the arm and I don't have the
exclusive edition edition actually came
with the ironmongers head and looking
back at it now I really should have got
it
because the statue is magnificent so let
me give you a little back history of on
Iron Man and what's the differences
between MCU and the comic books well an
MCU Ironman actually became the flagship
character that translated well on-screen
that got us all these wonderful movies
and it wasn't for lack of trying Marvel
tried with other characters but it seems
that Iron Man resonated the most his
stories rang true with the people and it
also stuck to the core of the character
now in the comic books Iron Man was
never the main guy always trying to be
always you know available but his
stories were some of the best stories
like a demon in the bottle when he was
struggling with alcoholism he got a
brief summary of that in some of his
movies with you know he will always have
a drink in his hand they never really
touched on it or armor Wars where his
technology was stolen and was all over
the place and he had to get it back and
he didn't really you know I appreciate
it and that was a really good take on
the character he also was part of
guardians of the galaxy he went into
space I like to MCU where Thor went into
space was really I am and I went into
space with the guardians of the galaxy
and then he had the extremest armor Tony
Stark is a futurist we wouldn't got
those stories and a little bit more
focused on Tony Stark had he not taken
off in the movies to be honest with you
um the fact that he did his visibility
was all over the place and trust and
believed the fact that you could market
a ton of toys wrapped around this armor
because he will always change up his
armors and I thought that was ingenious
to be honest with you because he never
stayed with the same armor my classic
Iron Man armor is dis armor right here
with the power packs on his
his waist there's an X M I a man that I
want basic basically from the age of
Ultron um to me age of Ultron was my
best Avengers movie so yeah definitely
want those lines and but as far as a
movie figure this is the one that I
needed and I wanted as you can tell from
the detail of the shoulders and
everything I thought that this Iron Man
was fantastic I am as nemesis and the
comic books has always been the Mandarin
and a lot of times Namor Doctor Doom
they always pair him up with whoever
they can get a good story out of Iron
Man with you know because remember at
the at the end of the day I a man isn't
a super combat guy so he's not like on
par and with Captain America as a
fighting technique he can program that
stuff into his armor and his armor can
fight but Iron Man is a man of vast
wealth billionaire philanthropist and he
sees as a playboy you know so and he has
a ton of money and he start turning
around he start seeing errors ways his
company's ways and now you know he wants
to be that hero he was always that
Herald but he found out through his
trials and tribulations that um he can
be that hero for the people and I'm so
happy that the MCU has embraced him in
the manner that they have because I
don't believe that we were got such
incredible stories that we did get later
on earlier on Iron Man was you know tech
driving his cars and stuff like that he
became the leader of shield like it and
they translate that stuff so well inside
the MCU
um I think Robert Downey jr.
has done a fantastic job with the
character and in the books he's welded
the gauntlet so the movies are accurate
in that standpoint I believe he's
probably one of the most MCU to
comic-book accurate characters that they
are I think they stayed really true to
his DNA they just told of a lot of the
stories in a manner that can fit and MCU
and it has worked out to the point that
it resonates well so it was very
heartfelt when the character was had to
die on screen he started it all and it
ended with him if you stayed to the last
credits you heard the beginning and what
endgame wanted you to understand was the
death of Tony wasn't the end of the
Avengers at the end of the MCU that ring
of him raped on building his armor that
was the beginning of the next phase the
beginning of the new MCU and going
forward you seen glimpses of that
throughout the movies this maquette here
shows strength
it shows power and remember I told you
that's what I asked for
and a lot of my statues so without
further ado guys I give you sideshow
mark 3 Iron Man maquette this
it's probably one of the standout
Ironman statues that you will get I
think we tell is somewhere between $6.99
aftermarket forget about it you could
probably still pick it up a sideshow as
a addition size of 1500 so might have a
couple more there left go check it out
see if you can get it but like follow
subscribe see you guys next week
well I have something that is so amazing
it's gonna knock your socks off and also
tune into ILP where we talk about gaming
the hot new takes on everything podcast
is incredible with the guys also we're
on our road to e3 so last week we did
Nintendo's prediction series this week
is Sony's prediction series you don't
want to miss that especially with this
guy in being a rare form so also go to
loads of gaming dotnet you can get all
information on III little video games
and opinion pieces from our great
writers have a ton of great writers
there that's putting up some top-notch
stuff and also for the ludus shooter
news I want you to tune into the last
word below Cognito
any bonta's listen guys right now
destiny 2 is at an all-time high and the
rage is rough for division 2 you do not
want to miss out all the information on
the updates and the new guns the nerves
the community's an uproar about all
those nerves that are going down to the
exotics and destiny to not this guy
I don't care hey
see you next week when I bring you the
new stuff but stay right here stay tuned
because I give you
scishow mark three maquette invincible
Iron Man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]